i'm curious man because uh
you and i are similar in age and i know
how much dmx meant to me coming up and
you know he's going through
his health situation and hopefully you
know what what did x mean to you like
from he passed
though
yeah man that [ __ ] [ __ ] that man
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up man
that [ __ ] x man x was a legend man
that dude was like a superhero to me as
a kid man like
i always always thought like you know
what i'm saying nobody could really [ __ ]
with x
like like no cap like i always thought
like
you know those [ __ ] that are probably
like you know albums and [ __ ] who i
might have liked more and all i said but
i'm just saying like
face to face if x pull up on you
you know what i'm saying you're not
[ __ ] with x man let me tell you
something when i was a kid i was 12
i went to the hard knock life tour and i
left after dmx got off stage i did not
even stay backs man i did not stand for
jay-z's performance five shows he
definitely he did that prayer [ __ ]
[ __ ] couldn't [ __ ] with x man no hype
man no nothing
bro i was so rough ridered out as a kid
i used to tag up that r on my [ __ ]
[ __ ] that [ __ ] true man rest in peace x
man recipes dark man x man
that's tough man damn [ __ ] [ __ ] up too
man we did didn't
join we just we on his hours and better
drop a new album
you guys got a record together that was
supposed to come out on the new album
yeah
damn down there record that [ __ ] winning
swiss joint how was that experience man
i didn't get to see him bro i never got
a chance to meet x in my life
you ever talked to him on the phone or i
don't know but he was he had been a fan
to get you on the album yeah
i seen him on the clip but um benny was
down there with him and nori and all
that
listening to the [ __ ] and all that so he
met benny
i don't know if west metal but i never
met i never met the og
man and um
and being on that record i was dying i
just
i was i was hoping that [ __ ] would be
there flew to atlanta
get in the studio but he was like sick
or some [ __ ] he didn't make it that
night you know what i mean so we just
did our verses and left but
damn man i hope that [ __ ] you know man
that's crazy man
i don't even know how to react right
neither do i man that's wild that
dmx my when i was for about two years of
my life as a kid he was my favorite
rapper in the world man
that's right too that's [ __ ] wild
i don't even know where to go from here
really like
um well look your album's coming out
r.i.p the dmx man
that's crazy [ __ ]
um just [ __ ] me up that [ __ ] me up
too
anything else you want to say man
man it really don't feel right to talk
about anything else yeah man
that's crazy yeah rest in peace to the
dog man
think about that two album run stark in
hell is hot flashing my flesh blood on
my blood
in the same year come on man oh
number ones come on he brought hey
when did he have the shiny shoes popping
dmx came but shut all that [ __ ] down bro
oh my god
damn yo it was crazy man i was a kid
when uh when big ian popped
you know saying when that [ __ ] happened
like
so i didn't really know how to react
with this [ __ ]
this this this [ __ ] me out right here
yeah man rest in peace to dmx man
that you know um conway got an album
coming out next week
yeah yeah yeah yeah like making that man
dropping that [ __ ] april 16th man there
it is